the Joe Rogan experience it gives me
some [ __ ] to think about that kind of
like propels me while I'm running don't
think I would you worry about getting
jacked what do you mean getting cat by a
cat oh you worry about that man yeah
definitely I've been hiking more than
ever lately and sometimes we're on some
trails where I have a rock ready to go I
carry a knife it's a good move a carry
knife when I run it's a good one yeah
it's not likely it's not likely people
call my god you're paranoid two people
were killed by mountain lions last year
and a kid got bit by a mountain lion
just a couple days ago Jamie I'm getting
over a cold folks from fi sound snotty
but if if two people got killed by
werewolves would you go out when the
moon is full you would like [ __ ] that if
two people on the Seattle got killed by
werewolves when there's a full moon
you're gonna lock your [ __ ] doors am
I in Seattle when I go out Seattle where
am I in Seattle
well the guy who's the werewolf could've
got on a plane and went to San Francisco
it's totally possible yeah right or just
walk but if you knew there was a real
werewolf that was on the full moon was
possibly gonna kill somebody sometimes
he didn't sometimes the full moon comes
and goes and nobody dies cuz everybody's
smart they all stay indoors yeah yeah
for sure yeah you would stay out but you
know the odds would be astronomical just
like like jaws like you know if you get
dropped in the middle of the ocean you
know the loo this guy it'll take this
guy has a [ __ ] mountain line and
that's all what is that that's not a
mountain lion that's like a that's a
domestic cat that a bobcat that looks
like I might a little cougar looks like
a no that's a domestic cat see those
ears it's like a really wild domestic
cat what is it called see see it's it
hisses Adam the guy might be a dick the
guy doing that [ __ ] what that cat
might be a dick he's trying to get it to
hiss I guess they have a good
relationship it looks like this where
were those two they look like that holy
[ __ ] that is a for what kind of animal
that's not links is it I don't know -
Stu doesn't the video doesn't say what
it is I saw I'm crazy
I saw links in real life once it's crazy
looking like a big these big giant
fluffy feet I saw him up in Alberta big
weird crazy feet like almost like
they're wearing shoes very strange
looking cat like a big old furry cat in
the woods in Canada it's so strange man
you look at me like what the [ __ ] are
you you ever see it links yes now I'm
not too sure what the difference between
the Lynx and a cougar that's what I saw
I saw him one of those [ __ ] I
was like why is there a fluffier bro
they're super hairy because they're cats
that lit that's what it's like that
won't the long legs right there Jamie
that's like exactly what I saw and it
was in the snow - or it was not in the
snow rather it was it was in the the
forest floor like green - and they the
feet are designed so that they can move
quickly over snow they almost act as
snowshoes like soda wolves like wolves
have big-ass feet and they spread out
that's what it looked like we were
driving down the road and we saw that
guy on the side of the road they were
like what is that what the [ __ ] it's so
weird to see one in real life if you see
it at the zoo you would even look at it
you'd pass by that age you feel like
what the [ __ ] is another looking Tigers
at whack-ass little cat and the crazy
polar bears but if you see it in the
woods man it's like the greatest thing
you've ever seen in your life
look at it look at it like a porcupine
if I see a porcupine and I'm driving
I'll stop my car look at that whoa what
do they still do they really shoot no no
they don't shoot you know they don't
shoot them no no no no no I do porcupine
and they don't shoot them they don't
shoot them that's a myth ah they just
have Barb's so if you bite them you get
to stock up
how crazy is that everyone thought that
throwing out like yeah in the 80s
because like they shot you with thorns
kids [ __ ] five probably tell their
dad you shot him at me dead or in a
cartoon or something yeah yeah that's
possible - right like everybody thinks
coyotes are stupid
yeah like jaws you know jaws pretty much
scared 95% of the population out of the
ocean oh yeah out of the ocean well I
just got jacked you heard about that guy
that just got jacked
right right yeah get well they don't
know what kind of shark got him but got
bitten Maui
I think Maui that's a lot of tiger
sharks right yeah yeah
surfer surfer um no I think it was a guy
staying at resort just swimmin mmm
died dead is far behind his body
they got him I mean they brought him
back to the beach but he had horrific
wounds he died it just happened yeah
just happened yeah man
sharks are no joke it's a terrifying
animal and again if there was a [ __ ]
werewolf running around the woods
exactly like and a werewolf just kill
the guy last week would you go to the
woods yeah I'd be just like jaws they
had it on the news no no let go but the
thing is that sharks are sharks 24 hours
a day seven days a week they don't only
on full moons become sharks but what
about what about guys that say that
that's totally blown on a proportion
they're right they swim with sharks they
get in there in the ocean with sharks
right there right I think the great
white is the only one that the divers
those crazy divers don't get in the
water with right but I think there was a
lady that swam with a great white
yeah there's pictures we were looking at
her Instagram page once young Jaime -
remember that lady yeah is it a trick
like she's knows things she knows if
it's pregnant you could go swim with it
or something you know like those videos
of babies playing with king cobras and
then you you find out that they defang
them right so they can't hurt you at all
they take away their venom sack - or if
they have a thing I might have made that
up yeah then I'm sack is that a real
thing I reckon nut sack shark tag
Brunswick the shark it's a 8 foot 9 inch
white shark that's been just recently
spotted yesterday or today I guess in
oceans outside of Ocean City Maryland oh
yeah yeah this is the way it's Twitter
account works
they like it speaks in the first person
what what if it kill somebody I'm sorry
he was tasty I think it's still gonna
keep up the Twitter account if we know
that shark killed somebody look if it
gets hungry enough all these [ __ ]
are overfishing the oceans you over fish
the [ __ ] out of those oceans financially
those sharks they're gonna turn on each
other
[Applause]